le 2 octobre 2018 jamal khashoggi
journalistes saoudiens et opposant
politique est assassiné au consulat
d'arabie saoudite à istanbul une partie
de la presse turque s'empare alors de la
fère et accuse ryad d'être responsable
de sa disparition
une information démentie par les
autorités saoudiennes
mais trois semaines plus tard changement
de ton le gouvernement saoudien mais que
le journaliste est mort dans le consulat
mais lors d'une rixe
un événement auquel réagi le prince
héritier mohammed bin salman
cet incident qui s'est produit est très
douloureux pour les saoudiens en
particulie pour les citoyens saoudiens
moi je ne pense que c'est douloureux
pour le monde entier c'est un aurait un
incident nous savons que beaucoup
essaient d'exploiter cette situation
douloureuse pour creuser un fossé entre
l'arabie saoudite et la turquie
je veux redire ici je n'y parviendrait
par le 23 décembre dernier cinq
saoudiens sont condamnés à mort par un
tribunal de ryad
au total onze suspects sont à ce moment
poursuivis dans le cadre d'une procédure
tenue secrète
à cette époque de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent et dénonce les méthodes des
autorités saoudiennes en matière de
justice
c'est le cas de l'omg reporters sans
frontières va se réjouir d'un tel
résultat
alors que l' enquête était manifestement
bâclé que les procédures
les audiences ont eu lieu à huit clos
sans qu'il soit impossible de savoir ce
qui se disait quels sont les éléments de
preuve
bref aujourd'hui à des condamnations des
acquittements mais tout ça semble assez
discrétionnaire la condamnation à mort
de cinq des accusés on peut que
l'interpréter comme une volonté de faire
taire à jamais des témoins ou même des
acteurs de cette horrible assassinat ce
meurtre plonge alors l'arabie saoudite
dans l'une des pires crises
diplomatiques de son histoire
un épisode qui ternit l'image de mohamed
bin salman et qui complique ses
relations avec la france la turquie et
des états unis
aujourd'hui le verdict de la justice
saoudienne est largement critiquée à
travers le monde